hallo leute wir haben heute besuch von
unserem freund joshua aus japan
willkommen in berlin
ja danke schön diesmal sind wir mit den
studenten gekommen die jetzt durch
lernen
schön dass wir uns besucht und wir haben
uns überlegt dass wir heute einen
spaziergang an der berliner mauer machen
und zwar sind wir gerade an der
gedenkstätte an der bernauer straße und
wir zeigen der gruppe jetzt hier wie
hier die mauer ausgesehen hat und wir
dachten wir machen auch darüber ein
video für euch los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die berliner mauer hat berlin für
insgesamt 28 jahre geteilt
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg wurde
deutschland in ja zwei länder geteilt in
ostdeutschland und westdeutschland und
berlin lag zwar im osten von deutschland
aber die besatzungsmächte haben damals
entschieden dass sie auch berlin in vier
zonen teilen möchten
und aus diesen vier zonen wurde
irgendwann diese zweiteilung der ostteil
der sowjetische teil und der west teil
der von amerikanern briten und franzosen
kontrolliert wurde
und da immer mehr leute in der stadt
schwer zu kontrollieren waren hat sich
ja ostberlin irgendwann entschieden
diese mauer zu bauen damit die menschen
nicht mehr von dem osten in den westen
fliehen können
die gedenkstätte hier an der bernauer
straße ist der bekannteste ort in berlin
um die mauer zu sehen und wenn ihr mal
nach berlin kommt solltet ihr unbedingt
auch hierhin kommen
hier kann man die mauer noch im
originalzustand sehen ist es wie ein
open air museum
aber es ist eben auch eine gedenkstätte
das heißt hier gedenkt man der menschen
die auch unter der mauer gelitten haben
diesen ort hinter mir nennt man das
fenster des gedenkens
man sieht hier fotos von den personen
die erschossen wurden als sie versucht
haben die mauer zu überwinden also ihr
land zu verlassen
und heute kann man sich auch hier die
geschichten von diesen menschen anhören
oder durchlesen
[Musik]
dieses bild ist eines der bekanntesten
bilder aus der zeit des mauerbaus es
zeigt einen jungen 19 jährigen soldaten
der mitten im dienst also während er
selbst die mauer bewacht aus seinem land
steht
[Musik]
für mich ist die ganze geschichte der
teilung berlins und auch deutschlands
irgendwie faszinierend denn heutzutage
wohl nicht ganz in der nähe von der
mauer und ich war hier einfach vorbei es
ist ein normaler ort für mich aber ich
weiß auch dass vor nur 30 jahren alles
anders war als die mauer gefallen ist
war ich erst sechs jahre alt und ich
erinnere mich noch ganz genau dass an
diesem abend mein vater zu mir kam für
mich aufgeweckt hat und mir ja unter
tränen erzählt hat dass etwas ganz
besonderes passiert ist und ich habe
damals überhaupt nicht verstanden
ja was das bedeutet heute verstehe ich
natürlich die geschichte und ich finde
es immer noch faszinierend zu sehen dass
sich so schnell einen ort ändern kann
berlin war vor 30 jahren geteilt und
menschen starben dabei das land zu
verlassen oder in den anderen stadtteil
zu gehen und heutzutage ist es eine
offene stadt die ja ganz anders ist ein
ganz frei ist und das macht mir auch
irgendwie hoffnung für viele andere
situationen die vielleicht heute sehr
bedrohlich wirken mögen aber die
vielleicht in der zukunft vielleicht
verändern sich die dinge schneller als
man denkt
[Musik]
das war unser video über die berliner
mauer wir hoffen es hat euch gefallen
und wenn ihr mal in berlin sein
dann solltet ihr unbedingt diesen ort
auch besuchen
danke schön dass ihr da rollt wir wir
gehen jetzt zusammen noch einen kaffee
trinken und ihr könnt die zeit nutzen
und weiter deutsch lernen nämlich unter
anderem mit unserem vokabeln und mit
interaktiven übungen wenn ihr ein
mitglied werde von easy german dann
bekommt ihr nämlich jede woche übungen
vokabeln und transkripte von uns
probiert das mal aus yazoo ist auch ein
mitglied der german und probiert es mal
aus wir freuen uns darüber
dankeschön und bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]